all right ladies and gentlemen I'm back
with another amazing video where I will
go over every single update from the one
and only George RR Martin in this new
video you're gonna see how often George
R Martin has thrown shade at Game of
Thrones writers David and Dan I think
some of you will be shocked by what he
did or didn't say because I know there's
a lot of you who are unaware of what he
said in all of these Game of Thrones
updates now some of you might be
wondering why why am I making another
video like this well if you remember I
recently made a video about every single
wins of winter update from George R
Martin it may have been one of the
greatest reminders of how he still
hasn't delivered the next A Song of Ice
and Fire novel well now I think it's
only fair that I throw some shade back
at David and Dan once again one of the
most upsetting things about all of this
was learning how David and Dan
essentially stopped asking for any help
on writing the show in fact George R
Martin revealed he no longer knew what
was happening inside Game of Thrones
writer's room after season four that was
when he said he wanted to shift most of
his focus on finishing the wins of
winter now although he did admit he was
the one who decided he would no longer
write episodes for the show he did not
want to be shut out of everything he
still wanted to be aware of which
directions they were heading in even if
they were no longer following his novels
during one of George R Martin's Infamous
interviews he said he was left out of
the loop after season four he went on to
say by season 5 and 6 and certainly
seven and eight I was out of the loop
when the interviewer asked him why he
simply said I don't know you have to ask
David and Dan then he throws another
shot at them when he said his experience
was much different while working with
House of the Dragon co-creator Ryan
condle again although George R Martin
admitted he no longer wanted to write
any more Game of Thrones episodes
himself still to this day he doesn't
know why David and Dan stopped involving
him with the show altogether the fact
that he always says you have to ask
David and Dan in regards to what was
happening with the show sounds like
George no longer had a say in anything
unfortunately these fractures and their
relationship as well what would lead to
George R Martin going on his social
media and throwing more and more shade
at David and Dan even while new episodes
of the show were airing on HBO now
before I get into everything else that
was said I have to let all of you know
about this amazing new offer I'd like to
thank the sponsor of today's video and
cogni now some of you might not know
this but so much of our personal
information is out there all over the
Internet spreading like wildfire as
we're online handling our business like
taking care of her bills banking or even
shopping for family or friends
unfortunately in this day and age the
likelihood of your information getting
breached on the Internet is always
increasing and that's because your
personal information is getting shared
and sold online without you even knowing
about it as someone who works on the
internet every single day this is
something I take very serious data
Brokers actually collect and sell your
information including your names and
aliases Social Security numbers login
credentials home addresses phone numbers
email addresses online activity and so
much more all of this information is
bought and sold on the internet every
day and you do not want it to fall into
the wrong hands thanks to incogni this
does not have to happen to you there's
hundreds of commercial databases and
people search the sites that hold your
information and that number grows every
year incogni will fight to have your
personal information removed from the
data Brokers immediately you might not
know this but data Brokers are required
to remove your information from their
databases if you ask them the only
downside is this can take months or even
years to do incogni will make sure all
of this is done for you automatically
they will reach out to the data Brokers
on your behalf request the data removal
and fight any objections for you and the
best thing about this is it's all
automated with their service
unfortunately I've had my own issues
before when my identity was stolen a
scammer was able to open up many
different lines of credit in my name
which then allowed them to spend money
on my behalf Not only was this very
stressful and a giant headache but it
was years before I was able to fully
resolve this issue this is one of the
many reasons why you should sign up for
an cognate today you don't have to live
through my same nightmare I signed up
myself and I'm so glad that I did all
you have to do is make your account and
enter the information that you want
removed after you give them the right to
work on your behalf you can sit back and
relax knowing that your information
isn't being sold I also love that I can
log in at any time and check the
progress and I can even see the massive
list of Brokers that had my information
most of which I've never heard of the
first 100 of you to use the code talking
Thrones will get 60 off in cogney click
the link in the description to take back
your information right now once again I
have to thank and cogni for sponsoring
today's video
all right now this is when it starts to
get very interesting as I'm sure most of
you already know Game of Thrones was
without a doubt the biggest show on
television during its seventh season
back then you could not get on the
internet without seeing every social
media site flooded with information
about Game of Thrones there was always
something new going viral after every
new episode well as Game of Thrones was
on everyone's mind back then George R
Martin would actually go onto his social
media to discuss another show now you
have to remember this was during the
middle of season seven this was not in
the off season while everyone was
waiting for the show to come back only
days after Game of Thrones would air one
of its biggest episodes when Daenerys
finally let her Dragon loose in Westeros
George R Martin instead decided to go on
his social media and discuss Netflix's
show instead of saying something about
Game of Thrones he said the second
season of The Last Kingdom based on
Bernard Cornwell's Saxon series was just
as good as the first I hope there will
be a season three now if that is isn't
throwing shade at the biggest show you
helped create then I don't know what is
Imagine The Creator and author going on
his social media to discuss another show
from another Network at the height of
Game of Thrones it may or may not have
something to do with him being left out
of the loop I'm sure it wasn't easy for
him to watch a show head in the wrong
direction when he already gave David and
Dana guideline during another one of his
interviews he gave more insight into
what actually happened to his
relationship with the Game of Thrones
writers finally George R Martin did
discuss the final season of the show he
said the final Series has been not
completely faithful otherwise it would
have to run for another five seasons the
article goes on to say he sort of dipped
his toe into the controversy while
talking to Fast Company the interview
was in their magazine not online
describing his feelings about what can
be lost in a book to screen adaptation
it can be traumatic he said because
sometimes their Creative Vision and your
Creative Vision don't match and you get
the famous creative differences thing
that leads to a lot of conflict now we
don't need him to hold our hand for us
to know he must be referring to David
and Dan as well I believe this is the
reason why their relationship fractured
I think it's why they no longer informed
him on what was happening with the show
Unfortunately they no longer cared what
he had to say their minds were made up
and they wanted to go in their own New
Direction during his interview with the
Rolling Stone he was asked about how he
felt about the show ending he said you
know it's complex I'm a little sad
actually I wish we had a few more
seasons but I understand Dave and Dan
are going to go on to do other things
and I'm sure some of the actors were
signed up for like seven or eight years
and they would like to go on and do
other things as well all of that is fair
I'm not angry or anything like that but
there is a little wistfulness in me it's
no secret we all know George RR Martin
did not want the show to end after only
eight seasons in fact HBO did not want
Game of Thrones to end that early either
the only ones who were adamant about the
show ending at after eight seasons was
David and Dan some of you may or may not
know this but George RR Martin actually
flew out to New York to bake an HBO
executive to make Game of Thrones 10
seasons long according to his agent
HBO's hit series Game of Thrones came to
an end in 2019 after delivering
shortened Seasons which brought the
total to eight seasons and 73 episodes
however the story's original Creator the
author George R Martin desperately
wanted 10 seasons and a hundred total
episodes according to a new book George
would fly out to New York to have lunch
with HBO's executive to bake him to do
10 seasons with 10 episodes each he said
it was because there was more than
enough material for it and to tell him
it would be a more satisfying and more
entertaining experience for the fans as
I said George R Martin and HBO's
Executives would have been happy with
more seasons but the show Runners David
and Dan had something else in mind
George R Martin also said David and Dan
were done and wanted to move on so they
cut it short and then negotiations
became game how many seasons can we
stretch this out because of course HBO
one and more Haas added George loves
David and Dan but after season five he
did start to worry about the direction
they were heading in because George
knows where The Story Goes he started
saying you're not following my template
or his guideline and as George was
watching Game of Thrones go down in
flames during its final season he went
online again to throw more shade at the
writers once again you have to look at
the date in which this update was made
what you're about to see is what George
said only days after the infamous long
night episode one has not a Blog he said
I saw the new Avengers movie last night
end game is amazing kudos to the writers
and director I cannot believe they got
all those characters into one film and
still managed to do them all Justice the
final battle was epic exciting thrilling
and full of twists and turns and
strangely beautiful but the character
scenes earlier in the film really made
it for me now doesn't that sound like
something he should have been saying
about Game of Thrones final battle you'd
think he would get all excited and hype
about Game of Thrones the biggest show
on television that he did help create
instead he went on social media to
express all those feelings about
something else and he made sure to let
everyone know while the fans were making
Game of Thrones go viral in the worst
way after all the backlash he got after
the long night episode even if he never
releases the ones of winter or the final
novel Game of Thrones final season will
never be the real ending to me now I
will leave you with one final update
from George R Martin by giving you
something to look forward to as a way to
end the video winter is coming I told
you long ago and so it is the Winds of
Winter is very late I know I know but it
will be done I won't say when I've done
that before only to burn you all and
jinx myself I will finish it though and
then will come a dream of spring how
will it all end I hear fans always
asking will it have the same ending as
the show or different well yes and no
and yes and no and yes and no and yes I
am working in a very different medium
than David and Dan never forget they
only had six hours for the final season
I expect these last novels of mine will
fill 3 000 manuscript Pages between them
before I'm done and of course the
butterfly effect will be at work as well
those of you who follow this not a Blog
will know that I've been discussing that
since season one there are characters
who never made it onto the screen at all
and others who died in the show but are
still alive in my novels so if nothing
else the readers will learn what
happened to Lady stoneheart Arianne
Martel Dark Star victarion Greyjoy aegon
the sixth Anna Myriad of other
characters both great and small ones who
the viewers of the show never had a
chance to meet and yes there will be
unicorns of a sword my novels or the
show which will be the real ending it's
silly really how about this I'll write
it you read it then everyone can make up
their own mind and argue about it on the
internet
[Music]
foreign